Jerry Springer has died at the age of 79
but what do we know about his death and
the incredible strange and controversial
life he led the famous talk show host
and Mastermind behind the Jerry Springer
Show was diagnosed with cancer a few
months ago but his condition worsened
earlier this week he was in his home
located in the Chicago area at the time
of his passing a family spokesperson
released a statement on behalf of the
talk show host's Family noting he was
loved by lots of people it read Jerry's
ability to connect with people was at
the heart of his success in everything
he tried he's Irreplaceable and his loss
hurts immensely but memories of his
intellect heart and humor will live on
of course Springer leaves behind an
impressive Legacy while he was primarily
associated with television he had a long
career that saw him take on a variety of
jobs ranging from political Pursuits to
movie roles prior to becoming one of the
most recognizable faces on television
Jerry Springer was a politician and a
supporter of the democratic party after
serving as Robert F Kennedy's political
campaign advisor he unsuccessfully ran
for congress in 1970 however he was
elected to Cincinnati city council the
following year and became the mayor of
the city in 1977. that said he was only
allowed to hold the position of mayor
for a year most people associate
Springer with his talk show which he
hosted for 27 years the Jerry Springer
Show Rose to prominence in the 1990s and
attracted a lot of controversy due to
the topics it covered the series
originally started out as a humble
political and news commentary show but
it truly took off after it started
covering stories about this kind of
stuff
foreign
critics often accuse the show of being
sensationalist and exploitative but
millions of viewers were captivated by
its content it wasn't uncommon for the
guests to start fights with each other
on the Jerry Springer Show but the drama
helped the series become a rating Smash
in the United States Springer's
controversial Juggernaut even Drew more
viewers in the Oprah Winfrey Show in the
late 90s which was no small feat at the
time Springer's success turned him into
a household name so it was only a matter
of time until he made the leap to acting
while his political career only saw him
work at the local level he did get to
play the president of the United States
in Dolph Lundgren's action thriller the
defender for the most part though
Springer was either cast as himself or
as characters with similar interests to
his own his most famous movie role is
ringmaster in which he portrays a talk
show host named Jerry farrelli while the
movie didn't set the box office on fire
it did showcase Springer's abilities as
an actor and proved that he was more
than happy to satirize himself in 1999
he had a brief cameo in Austin Powers
The Spy Who shagged me in which he
played himself in interview doctor evil
and his son okay all right get the shark
out of here
Springer also guest starred on several
TV shows from the X-Files to The
Simpsons his final acting role was on
the house arrest rooneys a comedy about
a family that gets caught up in an
insurance fraud scam meanwhile his last
General television appearance was on The
Masked Singer last year no doubt
Springer leaves behind a legacy as
unusual as the show that made him famous
foreign
[Music]